racismo letal Ese es el nombre del
informe presentado por amnistía
internacional en el que se denuncia uso
ilegítimo de la fuerza y ejecuciones
extrajudiciales durante el control de
las protestas que sacudieron al país
tras la destitución de Pedro Castillo
una respuesta con sesgo racial que
habría sido coordinada y tolerada desde
el estado y no casos aislados No
encontramos evidencia que ninguna de las
personas que fueron sometidas a
ejecuciones extrajudiciales o asesinatos
arbitrarios estaban empleando la
violencia en el momento que se utilizó
la fuerza letal en su contra amnistía
estudió en su informe 49 muertes se
manifestantes ocurridas en choques con
fuerzas del orden la mayoría de ellas en
el sur del país lo que permitió detectar
un patrón de estigmatización en contra
de poblaciones históricamente
discriminadas así como el empleo de
instancias de poder de un discurso de
odio nosotros
definitivamente nos gustaría ver
a los fiscales y a la fiscal de la
nación que investiguen si es que el
discurso por la presidenta y de otros
están en el marco del Artículo 20 de la
gobernanza internacional para lo que son
derechos civiles el informe se suma al
pronunciamiento de la semana pasada del
relator especial de Naciones Unidas para
la libre asociación que se declaró
alarmado por el uso excesivo de la
fuerza que causó más de 60 muertes
durante las protestas se espera que la
fiscalía tome declaración a la
presidenta Dina boluarte la próxima
semana sobre lo ocurrido durante las
manifestaciones